all right so this probably isn't the you
know beginning you were expecting for
this video but I just wanted to announce
the winner of the giveaway that I was
doing and if you guys don't know I just
did a 20 min giveaway for hitting 1,500
subs I thank you guys a lot but I end up
rambling way too much and as I do I
showed how I did it all in some clips
but then it ended up being like two
minutes long so I just want to say it is
LR DG I believe that is his RS name so
if you are watching this video right now
make sure to add me in-game I'll
probably end up messaging you on YouTube
as well since I haven't seen you in game
but yeah thanks everyone for commenting
and liking and I thank you all for being
at this position so with that being said
let's get into the video all right so
I'm also making this in post if you guys
can tell based on the fact that I'm in
catherby but I rambled on way too much
as I do in the beginning things I'm
going I'm just gonna get right into what
we're doing today so basically what I
found with wyverns is that maging them
with fire wave which does require 75
magic you can at my level 98 mage within
a beaut heart I don't have it with me
now imbued heart would highly recommend
but I sold it off since making the video
basically I found that you can get
around 60 2k is magic XP per hour and
also make 200k + GP per hour and it is
also afk one of the best magic training
methods I would imagine in the game
depending on what all you know or what
all you're looking for I'd say it's the
best all-around sort of thing like that
that rivals out getting almost a now
king is not a death cable at all so
basically what we're gonna get into and
I Det you know alright basically what
we're gonna get into now is the gear
setup so what you're gonna want is just
the best magic bonuses that you can get
so I have a rims right here I don't
think that voids better to be honest
saradomin cave occult necklace this is
just for one plus prior seers reign
eternal boots bears blow smoke battle
staff and home of fire so whenever you
first attack wyverns I'd recommend
putting on the minefield because if you
don't you can get owned for like a 45
it's pretty much like dragon breath so
you put that out for your first attack
once your safe spot you go ahead and
throw the time of fire on that's why I
have both Toma fire is very helpful
doubles
I think adds 50% to what you would have
hit so obviously you get a lot more xp
for that if you don't have the money for
it you can just do this regularly the
only things that you can improve upon I
believe with this setup is just getting
zenite gloves or zenite bracelet and I
think that's honestly it so you're gonna
want the best magic bonuses that you can
get obviously and then go over to the
inventory it's pretty simple I had an
imbued heart and that's what I did my
testing with if you guys can afford in
the beaut heart I would highly recommend
it it's very helpful it's pretty much
like an infinite magic potion while
you're there in the inventory I have
three prayer potions a monkfish and a
ring of dueling also a room pouch to
hold your nature's and bloods which you
are gonna need you're gonna need Bloods
to go ahead and use fire wave and
nature's two-out also you're gonna need
a Remington teleport I didn't bring it
up cuz I actually don't plan on
teleporting from here but feel Rutten
teleport go ahead and grab that so now
I'm going to go into how you would plan
on getting there
so if you guys don't know where wyverns
are [__] me all right I'm gonna teleport
do Remington then you guys to see where
why birds are goddamnit alright so as
you can see if we go to the map and
scroll out a little bit so as you can
see off over here this is mudskipper
point this little little exclamation
point right here is where wyverns are
located just south of falador so once
you teleport to Remington if you have
the house teleport there you're just
going to want to follow my lead and I
will be back here in a second
[Music]
all right so drink up on your energy
potion if you need I mean realistically
if you have a decently high agility
level you might not even need one to get
to the very beginning but just go ahead
and drop that so as you can see we are
here where the wyverns are you're gonna
want to throw on your mind shield
basically you need the mind shield
because they have some crazy fire breath
that just destroys people and whenever
you first go in here you will be a grout
so I'm going to go ahead and get off my
aggro just for a second by you know if
just doing this basically the reason
that I'm gonna show you guys right now
as to why you want automa fire in a mine
shield is once you have them safe
spotted and I'll kind of show you the
safe spots as we go this is one
basically the wyvern that's spawned
right here you just stand on the very
first block right here you can always
tell by the spaces like this one right
here and you can actually have it safe
spot it without doing anything and since
it can't attack you you can put on
whatever shield you want problem is is
if you miss click and run towards it or
anything you may get like destroyed and
I'm pretty sure at lower stats on top of
that you could go the other way if you
want this is the safe spot as you can
see this guy this is like a square that
doesn't have any like overlay over it
like as you can see like the pebbles and
stuff that's not on the square so that's
really easy to identify you can also go
down here but I usually don't mess with
these you can stand right there and get
that one and then over there I've never
messed with so I have no clue but
basically what I'm gonna do is go ahead
and do this for an hour to see how many
or how much money we make and drops and
you know how much xp we can get and kind
of sum it up for you guys and what I
think the pros and cons of this method
are so as you can see I am a grub right
now so that's girl to wife I was about
to get me so I threw on my mind shield
you just gotta stay on your feet while
you are a ground once you're on aggro
though it's very very easy alright so it
is one minute before the hour but here
we are we are done for now I think I got
decent drops for what you could expect I
got a lot of ran our seed so I didn't
get any battle staff so I think it all
kind of evens out I feel like I got
relatively unlucky except for the ran
our seeds if I didn't get many ran our
seeds this would have been a very non
representative drop rate alright so what
I was able to figure out was that I got
about 48 to 49 kills in an hour for the
most part as you can see I have a ton of
prior potion so if you wanted to just
camp mystic might you could do
that I tried to flick and I probably did
for about 75% of all the kills and yeah
I mean it worked out pretty well for me
what I figured out as far as XP wise was
that magic I got 61k XP in an hour prior
I buried all my bones I got like 3.5 K
or so XP in an hour and then with hit
points I was able to get like 12 K the
reason you have so little hit points and
so high of magic and it's not like
proportional three-to-one it's because
of the you know just XP that you get for
splashing on on wyverns but yeah so
basically I think I started this hour
with around 1.3 K blood runes and we are
down to 328 as you could see right up
here just want to open it so you can see
it but uh so 1k blood runs caused me
about 270 K so I'm going to go ahead and
price check everything we got here it
give me a second alright so as you can
see here in the hours time I was able to
make 556 K you subtract 270 from that
that's almost around 300 K or so profit
in this hour one other thing that I do
have to take into consideration I guess
is that I did use a thousand Tomo fire
charges and a thousand of those caught
is about I think it's fifty yeah a
thousand is fifty Toma fire pages and
the pages go for I believe two to three
K so that's about 100 K less so
realistically in an hour I was able to
get 600 I was able to get 61k magic XP
and make between 2 to 250 K I mean
realistically if you had a little more
lucky with drops while I did get some
ran ARS if you get to battle staff drops
which I would say at least 1/2 maybe to
an hour's probably average then this
just negates all of that and I got
relatively unlucky with other like Ruby
drops and stuff like that so that's what
I found out for this I feel like it's a
pretty decent money making method I mean
not money making method but as far as
like training magic and looking to make
a little money on the side this is
relatively just insane I mean there's
there's obviously better ones that you
can do but this is something that will
always be there it doesn't rely too
heavily like my blue like my dragon hide
tanning method it doesn't rely too
heavily on stuff like that
so it's very good for consistent
money-making it consists of mage XP so
alright some of you guys enjoyed the
video
you guys didn't feel free to hit that
like button if you guys have any ways I
can improve upon feel free to comment
about them down below if you guys want
to see more of my videos go ahead and
click that subscribe button and you'll
be alerted as soon as my videos go live
nonetheless hope you guys have a
wonderful day